welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who came from
the shallow end of the gene pool in this
video we're breaking down the latest
episode of better called soul
[Music]
after last week's massive time jump that
took us to the days of breaking bad we
get a further one in this entry with a
shooting right up to the aftermath of it
with jimmy under his new identity gene
the entire episode is in black and white
and i've always kind of viewed this as
being for a symbolic reason when we're
dealing with gene sure it's to
differentiate between the past and
present whereas normally in other shows
and movies they might flip this round
having the future scenes color graded
like this creates a very binary presence
got another colourful suit and
over-the-top personality of jimmy and
it's been filled with this very monotone
low-key lifestyle that he's now having
to live even though he's free gene
clearly isn't happy and throughout the
seasons we've got the sense of paranoia
and longing in this episode we see as
the slick talking soul starts to return
and the con man is back in full effect
hints of this are even given to us in a
brilliant scene in which jimmy shows
he's got a passion for fashion with a
snazzy tie and sheer combo now this has
to be patent because it's all in black
and white and if it was just colored we
wouldn't be able to see this so nice
attention to detail there also i'm
probably going to be using seoul jimmy
and jean interchangeably but you know
who i mean yet please don't butcher me
in the comments either way we are going
to be diving into it all but if you
enjoy the video i'd massively appreciate
the thumbs up and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day by the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into better cool soul
now the episode is heavily centered
around jeff the cab driver who has
appeared in earlier flashbacks my name
is jeff
back in season four episode one after
gene left hospital he got picked up in
jeff's cab his mother marion at one
point mentions famous people jeff had in
his taxi one of which was sammy hagar
and she and jimmy proceed to sing icon
drive 55 calling back to this ride now
gene noticed in albuquerque isotopes air
freshener and after recognizing him it
seemed like the walls were closing in on
jimmy the air freshener wants more
returns in this entry when we see jf
returning home from work good to episode
one of season five and jeff approached
gene in the mall whilst he was on a
break recognizing him he brought in his
menacing mate who i'll send after you if
you don't subscribe and he did his
catchphrase after finally dropping the
act in magic man gene vowed to fix his
situation himself and we see the
resolution of this in this entry now
someone clearly fixed jeff's face as
he's a completely different actor this
was apparently due to contractual
obligations and let me know below which
geoff you prefer and we begin with
marion who is introduced with this line
can i give you a hand if i needed a hand
i'd ask for it thank you very much she
of course ends up needing a hand later
on so this is a great way to set up how
slick jimmy is as he's able to even
penetrate the hottest shell of marion as
she tries some schnootz forms schnauze
forms which have dips next to them and i
dunno kinda reminded me of the german
chip and dip stuff from breaking bad
thank you for not turning off the video
for that reach if you're still with me
and on her way home marion gets stuck in
the snow this is the first part of the
con as we discover that she travels on
this route regularly and that the snow
wasn't to that level when she came out
earlier jimmy is enacting the first part
of his plan attempting to seem
sympathetic by hanging up missing dog
adds on a tree he puts up several of his
poor puppy nippy and tells a story about
how he got lost in the snow and hasn't
been seen since now we're back to
reaching yeah but i think jimmy told
this story to plant the idea in marion's
head that the same thing could happen to
her after cutting her breaks gene pushes
her all the way home and we discover
that she's jeff's mother after a great
title sequence last episode ended with
seoul putting down the world's greatest
lawyer coffee mug which he had now
symbolically attained due to kim leaving
throughout the series he carried a flask
with second greatest lawyer on it but
this changing over for the breaking bad
stuff symbolized how it was now just him
the tape footage also ends up stopping
which metaphorically shows us the law
firm is an end now we could to jeff
coming home to see saul shacking up with
his mother we learned that this entire
episode is basically about jimmy setting
up jeff to be a criminal so that he
can't snitch on him because he could
potentially go to jail too i love this
line early on from marion and that of
course has a double meaning to it don't
worry hon he's not an axe murderer if he
was gonna chop me to abyss he'd have
done it already right gene
jimmy is obviously on the run for being
a criminal mastermind and i love the way
this line makes jeff feel even more
afraid that he doesn't really know who
he's dealing with also i've kind of
always thought that the design of gene
was meant to be based on btk who like
jimmy was hiding a dark secret under the
guise of being a mild-mannered looking
man now it's theory time no time
so i actually think that marion might
end up being the one who tells the
police about gene towards the end of the
episode she talks about how jeff fell in
with a bad crowd all the way back in
albuquerque something terrible must have
happened and the pair got scared and
jeff ended up moving out with his mama
to ballet now i think marion might end
up finding out about the crime that the
pair committed together and being
worried the albuquerque situation could
happen once more she might tell the
police i believe that the second jeff
recognized him that his days were
numbered and i don't think the
resolution of this entry is as simple as
him now being off the hook let me know
your thoughts below but that's the end
of your time new time
dude
now the pair take out the trash together
and jimmy correctly guesses that jeff
wants in the game similar to jimmy he
probably also misses his life back in
albuquerque and the bad crowd likely
lured him in with the same things that
are promised to him here he probably
also regrets having to flee and wants
some excitement back in his life which
leads to him being tempted by one of the
biggest bad boys out there now jimmy is
still clearly paranoid too and that
night we see as he returns home and puts
on his police radio now this could be to
see whether jeff's contacted them but
due to the way it's set up i can imagine
that it's a daily routine he's likely
constantly listening out for whether the
police are going to come to his door and
i can imagine this will be something
that plays into the finale now yours
ends up digging out a shoebox of his old
belongings and he puts a marco's ring
which he then wears for the rest of the
entry this belonged to his old partner
in crime and throughout the series it's
been something that he's fiddled with
before either making a dangerous or
important decision it being put on back
here shows that the con is on and that's
all might be gone but he's not forgotten
he packs up some cinnabons and goes to
the security guard office under the
guise of thanking them for calling the
emts after he fainted we see that the
main security guard frank is played by
jim o'hare who you might recognize as
playing jerry sorry gary in parks and
rec jimmy has worked out when the other
does his checks and with frank being a
bit of a plum figure with a hot daughter
he's the one that jimmy can use the
cinnabon to control he times how long it
takes to eat and this gives him a rough
idea of how long jeff has to boost them
all later on he even bullshits his way
through the game's small talk and makes
it a regular occurrence we also see the
sg was here carving and after all his
visits he clocks up an average duration
of how long he has frank's attention for
the music that we hear over the top of
this scene also pulls from the original
mission impossible tv show giving this a
heist type feeling as we watch all the
pieces fall into place slowly he builds
a rapport with the security guards and
by the end of it he's their best friend
miming playing football with them and
talking about the game seoul is clearly
back and the suit scene cements this he
counts paces and we saw something
similar with gerst back in episode 5
when he set things up with the gun this
allows him to create a layout of the
entire mall floor so that jeff can run
through it i actually love heist movies
and shows and watching the pieces fall
into place for this was great in my
opinion now at the moment the general
vibe i've seen is that this is a bit of
a filler episode i think it was pretty
important to show how gene was going
back to being saul i think this will
have consequences for later on and can
imagine that either the security guards
or marion end up discovering who he is
and we also get this nod to walter white
50 year old high school chemistry
teacher comes into my office
the guy is so broke he can't pay his own
mortgage one year later he's got a pile
of cash as big as a volkswagen that
night a crate is dropped off at the
store and this has the number 19683 ae
35 which i believe is a nod to 2001 a
space odyssey cathy ends up holding the
box overnight and we discover that jeff
is inside of this she then goes to the
security room and we see that his
blagging of sport has now turned into
actual knowledge he's clearly studied
the game just to pull off this cod and
it's always great seeing the jimmy slash
soul persona back jeff makes his move
but he ends up tripping in the middle of
this door which leads to the tensest
scene in this entry now all the items he
steals are of course expensive clothes
and these are things jimmy wore in his
previous life however he's had to hide
them and be humble due to being on the
run but clearly he has this longing for
them
maybe maybe not the high heels but yeah
lots of items like this now they only
end up stealing three articles each so
that it won't allow suspicion amongst
the stock takers i love how jeff also
has a little rhyme here that he mutters
to remind him of what order to do the
job in anyway with jeff passed out jean
ends up breaking down to buy time but he
actually talks about himself he goes
over how his brother is dead and how he
lost his wife this sadness comes from a
genuine place and it buys jeff time to
[ __ ]
sorry about that
either way it buys jeff time to get out
now we learned that the tapes get erased
every 72 hours as well and the crate is
getting picked up in the morning so the
job is a go jimmy once more has a panic
attack though and it's a very touching
moment now jeff hides out in the toilets
and that morning he leaves when the
general public come in jeff smirks about
it but this mutually assured destruction
has a darker side to it with jimmy
saying we're done this of course calls
back to breaking bad when he tried to
say the same thing to walt and got this
response
we're done
when i say we're done
either way after all that a happy ending
and back at work gene has a spring in
his step he returns to the scene of the
crime creates an outfit soul would wear
and though he leaves us hanging up the
thrill he experienced this episode might
be too tempting not to return to and
that closes things out and i do feel
like the pieces set up here will return
at some point to have bigger
consequences obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts though so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you they're messaging me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
latest westworld episode which will be
linked on screen right now lots of stuff
to talk about in it things that you've
probably missed let's be honest mate you
missed them so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace